all right welcome back [ __ ] am i oh yeah
I got my glass jar of acid we're gonna
use that on the lock hopefully hopefully
I'll make it there alive
I have died in once now it was not
pleasant am I supposed to go in there
again no can't go back there's no going
back Daniel
it's our [ __ ] sure
all right
I wouldn't be surprised if he'd pop out
one more time before
that's the price at all
I think it's downstairs somewhere
so dark
Oh already not scared yeah great
think it's down here
nope
right they wasn't down there all right
think it's over here
am I out of all God I thank God have
plenty of oil don't worry you got this
no problem yeah here it is
hopefully we can use this [ __ ]
I'm out of ideas
I'm really out of ideas here
confusing
really is
say the least
have you been in the kitchen
don't forget being here
Oh God
that is a dead body
oh geez
it's fresh and [ __ ]
nice ass that ass
here's a bucket you poo bucket sorry bro
those not cool all right say shaky and
cutscene never good news
[Music]
do I deserve this yeah it wasn't my
fault
what wasn't why did you have to go in
true let's wait for him to growl Oh Tina
Mott's honor I might have missed they're
so sneaky
into the darkness
because why not
a note
[ __ ] you
mmm-hmm let's read this
get up Daniel holders 18:39 the
nightmares woke me in the early morning
and for a moment I forgot where I was
shortly after there was a knock on my
door Alexander had heard my screams and
asked me to join him in the parlor as in
a drank sounding bad news and I began to
tell me what he knew it seems like the
all I found casts a long and dark shadow
it's not only a powerful item but a
dangerous lure le simply by touching it
you invoke the powers within and if you
are too weak to control it it will
devour you the shadow is a sluggish
thing lagging behind the wielder killing
anyone or anything in its path to
reclaim me more I said I didn't care
about his powers and I should throw it
away
Alexander advised against this as I'd
still be a part of the path to the or
and eventually suffered death having the
orb
I would at least have the chance to
fight back when the time came I asked
Alex Allah Jesus meant when he said he
could protect me and he answered the
things can be done o that at a price and
whenever that is
you're gonna moan at me [ __ ]
hate him so much well this didn't really
help us get through that door or
anything so that's kind of annoying I
don't why I had this up yeah
and set steamy oh okay
I still know
where
do you see him
everything Oh if he had been behind me
once more F I wouldn't have played this
game anymore
you see there
I can't see
no way
he's freaking moaning so much lately
it's like it's on his period or
something
usually it just pops up like to one or
two other areas
yeah no thought I saw something
well I'm not going out there now
any protection
got bread okay
read first
I bet that's bodies gonna be gone
hmm I got a feeling a big scare is
coming
I confused I don't know what I'm
supposed to do
all right
let's get out of here sick of this place
oh you can lean
cool
and forgot about that
there is a lock somewhere not down there
though I don't run over out of oil while
I do this
I think I found the strong lock so
that's why I
you know didn't work I used it on a
strong law it's supposed to use it
there's a law
right and this is a strong one I think
very poor all right great
Oh
oh [ __ ] you dude get the hell out of
here
yeah relic love protecting the orb
Alexandra reached out to pick it up and
held it up against the light cover it he
said keep it